-Michael, I thought
it would be fun -- "No more."
-No more.
-For us to play a game.
I know you like games, right?
-Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah, so, this is a game
that I know
you're going to be great at.
It's called
"Slow Turn, Tiny Nod."
-♪ Slow Turn ♪
-♪ Tiny Nod ♪
-Now, the game is very simple.
One at a time, while maintaining
the utmost composure,
we will very slowly turn
our heads, look into camera,
and do the
tiniest head nod possible.
-Okay.
-Whoever does the best slow
turn, tiny head nod will win.
And you're not allowed to laugh.
And you'll go first.
You ready for this?
-Yeah.
-Alright. Michael, go ahead.
Slow turn, tiny nod.
Whenever you're ready.
[ Dramatic music playing ]
[ Laughter ]
-Can I start again?
-Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Of course.
-Hey, I know the point is
for you to enjoy yourselves,
but you could help me out here.
-Don't blame the audience.
Come on.
Here we go. Come on, now.
-We're a team.
[ Dramatic music playing ]
-Geez, this is ridiculous!
How does anybody do this?
-You tried. It's my turn now.
It's my turn. Here we go.
-Alright, fine.
-You lost that round.
It's a very hard game.
[ Clears throat ]
Here we go.
[ Laughs ] Alright.
Ah-ha!
[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
-He can't even start.
I at least started.
[ Dramatic music playing ]
[ Drumroll ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow.
It's like you don't have
any feelings.
-That's not true.
Let's do Round 2, okay?
Let's up the stakes a
little bit, right?
Even slower.
And then,
when you reach the camera,
you have -- you got to
flare your nostrils twice
and then a tiny nod.
-Mm-hmm.
-I won't look at you.
I won't look at you.
[ Dramatic music playing ]
-[ Humming ]
[ Drumroll ]
[Bleep]
-I had to look -- I had to look
because I was excited.
I had to look
The magic was happening
right in front of me.
What was I supposed to do?
So, turn, nose flare,
and then tiny nod.
Here we go. Ready?
[ Dramatic music playing ]
[ Drumroll ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
-Round 3.
-When you hear the noise
"Round 3,"
that means it's Round 3.
This is -- this is it.
This is for 5,000 points.
You're going to win.
All you have to do is --
This is the last one.
Turn your head, okay?
Look into Camera 3.
-3. Yeah.
-Shimmy your shoulders.
-Shimmy my shoulders.
-While you say, "Looks like
we got dinner plans."
-"Looks like we got
dinner plans."
-"Looks like
we got dinner plans."
-Obviously,
I'm going to be able to do this.
-And then, finally, give
a tiny nod, maybe, at the end,
if you feel like doing it.
'Cause you haven't really
completed any of the tasks.
-Right. I know.
Should I flare my nostrils, too?
-You know, surprise me.
I mean, this is your take.
-Alright.
-I'm not looking.
Oops.
[ Dramatic music playing ]
[ Drumroll ]
-Ooh.
Looks like we got
dinner plans tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's how you do it
right there!
That was "Slow Turn, Tiny Nod"!
My thanks to Michael Shannon!
"Nine Perfect Strangers"
premieres tomorrow on Hulu!
That is how you do it!